[Musique]
bonsoir à tous vous avez de la chance ce
soir on vous propose d'assister à la 13e
édition du concours simen cette soirée à
la villa du département et le concours
des femmes artistes amateurs et la
journée du 8 mars la Journée de la femme
et le cadre tout r trouve pour cette
belle soirée c'est
[Musique]
parti vous avez vu tout le monde arrive
au fur et à mesure à la villa pour cette
soirée du prix sellimen des femmes
artistes amateures des gens du monde
culturel réunionnis alors tout le monde
se demande mais c'est qui cette
[Musique]
sellimen cétait un personnage
effectivement célèbre qui toujours
célèbre à la Réunion elle était poétesse
chansonnière et c'est une un personnage
qui a vécu durant la première moitié du
19e siècle elle est morte en en 1864
elle tenait un relais de poste sous la
commune de à la Saline sous la commune
de dans les hautes de Saint-Paul et les
gens venaient la la rencontrer puisque
comme c'était un relais de poste la
diligence passait par là les visiteurs
pouvaientent se reposer un peu se
désaltérer voir même se restaurer et le
temps passé dans cette cette auberge en
fin de compte qui était une auberge
c'est Céline m prenait souvent sa
guitare et puis se mettait à improviser
chanter des des chansons et des vers qui
l'ont rendu
célèves dans S ver effectivement on voit
une liberté une liberté où simen aime
s'amuser utiliser des tournures à la
fois en français et à la fois en créol
et dans ces ver il pouvait même y avoir
des des critiques envers ou ses voisins
effectivement qui n'étaient pas
forcément des personnages très
sympathique voir même des notables de
l'époque qu'elleelle se permettait à
travers effectivement son son écriture
de se moquer gentiment de railler un
petit peu ses ses personnalités ses
figures
locales
c'est une jolie petite guitare
romantique hein tel qu'on pouvait les
trouver donc durant la première moitié
du 19e siècle donc d'une facture qui
peut tout à fait correspondre aux
instruments qui étaient fabriqués à
cette époque là voyez que c'est une
guitare beaucoup plus petite par rapport
à la guitare actuelle ou à la guitare
classique avec un des motifs décoratifs
notamment ici pour le cordier vous voyez
des des moustaches qui sont sculpté donc
cette cette guitare effectivement a fait
l'objet d'une de restauration ce qui
permet effectivement de de présenter
aujourd'hui l'instrument mythique qui a
accompagné C lorsquelle lorsquelle
chantait et improvisait dans
[Musique]
sonage plus que quelques minutes avant
le début de cette 13e édition du prix
avec moi l'équipe de la Direction de la
Culture et des Sports c'est un
engagement ça représente quoi le prix
sellimen sellimen aujourd'hui est devenu
un rendez-vous très important dans le
calendrier culturel de la réunion je
crois un un rendez-vous très régulier
aussi pour la journée de la femme et
pour nous l'équipe de la Direction de la
culture c'est un rendez-vous qui est à
la fois obligatoire puisque ça fait
partie de notre travail mais c'est un
rendez-vous très agréable très joyeux
qui demande beaucoup d'investissement
mais mais on est une équipe et comme
Françoise l'a dit on est une équipe
formidable rendez-vous attendu aussi
vous avez des des amateurs qui arrivent
des femmes amateures avec la beauté du
mot amateurisme on va dire oui c'est des
femmes amateures donc ce sont des
artistes entre guillemets qu'on a pas
l'habitude de voir qu'on ne connaît pas
du tout donc c'est une vraie découverte
chaque année et ce sont des découverte
plutôt plutôt heureuse donc encore une
fois on travaille mais on travaille
comme d'habitude dans la joie et dans la
bonne humeur alors c'était un moment
particulier ce moment où de la remise
des œuvres direction la Direction de la
Culture le cœur de l'organisation à la
rue générale de Goul jeun VIè vient de
Saint-Denis son œuvre sous le bras elle
profite de ces derniers jours pour
rendre son tableau à la Direction de la
Culture et des Sports du département oh
je suis revenu plusieurs fois il y a
toujours des retouches à faire mais à un
moment donné il faut savoir dire stop et
ça c'est le plus dur je crois que
parfois on peut-être on se sous-estime
ou mais je je trouve que l'action est
belle par rapport à la femme et c'est
mettre en valeur peut-être le fait que
Ben dans chaque femme il y a peut-être
une artiste qui sommeille réceptionné
par les agents du Département ces femmes
artistes amateurs laissent leur création
toutes n'ont pas le même lien la même
histoire un moment d'émotion hommage à
Sarah B Bartman pardon et c'est quoi
cette histoire en fait c'est c'est une
esclave qui qui a cause de ses forme
généreuse a été exposé comme un animal
devant ses maîtres et devant les autres
je suis débutant dans la peinture et on
va dire que je je rêveraiis de de me
faire connaître un peu j'aide donc les
femmes notamment de la réunion à à
s'accepter pleinement à avoir une
meilleure estime d'elle-même donc le but
voilà c'est de se réconcilier avec ce
que l'on est bah vraiment profondément
et de doter un peu tous les artifices
qui bah bien souvent ne nous nous
embellisse pas forcément j'ai voulu
mettre en valeur la Réunion le titre de
mon tableau c'est sensationnel et divine
DIN morgabine j'adore painre et jusqu'à
maintenant c'était dans le cadre de mon
foyer ça restait vraiment tous les
tableaux étaient accrochés à la maison
et là mes enfants m'ont poussé ils m'ont
dit maman essaye un petit coup et voilà
peinture sculpture photographie relevant
du domaine des arts visuels sont les
matières imposées plus de 200 œuvres
sont ainsi en liste cette année elles
sont toutes
toute pleine d'émotions au moment de
déposer leurs œuvres parce que ben c'est
ça ça rappelle leur attachement à cette
œuvre qu'ils ont passer du temps à à
confectionner donc c'est vraiment c'est
c'est chaque année c'est pareil le prix
sellimen est le plus ancien concours
culturel amateur de la Réunion un
engagement de la collectivité qui a
trouvé sa place dans le paysage culturel
c'est la chance donné à des femmes
artistes amateurs dans le secret de leur
atelier qui n'ont jamais exposé et qui
n'osent pas montrer leur travail c'esten
c'est la chance qui leur est donné de
montrer pour la première fois dans un
très beau cadre avec une belle
cédographie ce travail qui n'est pas
connu inviter les femmes à poser un acte
c'est leur donner du courage en même
temps toutes ces œuvres seront exposées
pendant un mois à la villa du
département rue de Paris à Saint-Denis
et c'est tout naturellement le 8 mars
que sera décerné le Prix sellimen 2017
[Musique]
retour à la villa du département et oui
c'est le soir et à côté de nous des
jeunes de Saint-Joseph qui ont participé
au Prix simen junior c'était quoi cette
aventure là cétait une expérience à
vivre et on remercie déjà notre
professeur madame Camon de nous avoir
fait vivre cette expérience mais c'était
quoi vous avez fait un tableau vous avez
fait une sculpture vous avez fait quoi
on a fait un tableau qui s'appelle
égalité fragmentée qui représente la
femme avec différents symboles en tout
cas bon concours bon conours prix
sellimen à vous passz une bonne soirée
il faut quand même qu'on vous parle
maintenant de ce prix sellimen du
concours lui-même alors il y a quelques
jours les membres du jury se sont réunis
ici à l'intérieur cétait sport la
délibération était vraiment tendue et
l'occasion pour nous de vous présenter
la présidente de ce jury direction
[Musique]
Paris
bonjour bienvenue mais rentré là on est
dans mon salon alors je m'appelle
Amalia et je suis artiste Damien mon
mari il travaille lui sur ordinateur
mais il fait de la scénographie
euh et et les et mes enfants ils font de
la musique voilà et il fait
aussi il fait aussi des des éoliennes
c'est les objets dehors que vous avez
filmé d'accord euh on m'a proposé de
deevenir présidente là cette année pour
le jury
simen à la
Réunion je je pense que c'est mes
orésines malgaches et le fait que je
travaille sur Madagascar qui ont fait
que ce ce choix a été euh fait je suis
très heureuse vite dans mon
[Musique]
atelier j'ai pas de médias
privilégiés je fais
plutôt la peinture la photographie des
montages et des installations j'aime
bien le côté un petit peu mystérieux je
travaille beaucoup sur les portraits et
j'ai tendance à les mass les portraits
beaucoup parce que je travaille sur les
portraits de famille et sur les masques
aussi les les les identités le tombeau
familial
d'accord tout ça c'est des photos de de
Mad en fait c'est une famille que je
connais que je connais pas puisque je
travaille ici en France sur Madagascar
beaucoup et sur cette famille et j'ai je
j'ai des trous dans mon histoire et et
donc j'ai j'ai c'est des gens que on m'
parl mais je les je les connais pas en
fait donc je les ai un peu manipulé j'ai
essayé de me me les approprier ces
gens-là à travers leurs images leurs
photos moitié femme moitié animal c'est
ça va au-delà de l'image là c'est sur du
papier qui se froisse donc l'idée de
l'idée c'est vraiment d'avoir un papier
un peu transparent fragile qui réagit à
l'encre de
Chine va tirer sur le papier ça va faire
des petits voyz ça va froisser un petit
[Musique]
peu ça c'est plutôt un lieu qui est très
lié à mon quotidien qui près de chez moi
donc j'aime bien aussi ner avec les gens
qui sont qui font des choses dans le
territoire où j'habite ça me permet de
planter quelques
[Musique]
racines
qu'est-ce que tu regardes en premier
quand tu regardes une quand tu VASER tu
vas regard qui je regarde d'abord
l'ensemble et après je rentre à
l'intérieur de l'œuvre si on peut dire
et en fait je suis très sensible à la
matérialité de l'œuvre par exemple ça
c'est des photos mais pour moi ça n'est
pas que des
images donc je dirais que l'art c'est la
vie mais c'est une vie qui est
travaillée qui est mise en valeur qui
est qui est qui est partagé aussi c'est
des choses qu'on partage aussi avec avec
les autres ça devient de l'art peu à peu
c'est pas quelque chose qui sort de
terre comme
[Musique]
ça retour dans la chaleur rayonnaise où
Amalia va bientôt annoncer la gagnante
du prix sellimain mais excusez-moi en
attendant je dois faire une vidéo pour
le facebook live du département le
prixen 2017 qui sera remis par notre
viceprésidente madame Sismo béatrice est
remis à alors pas je dis de bêtises
tanzili bassero
Béatrice bravo félicitations à vous je
peux vous embrasser merci
félicitations de l'émotion dès là enfin
c'était C oui je m'y attendais pas du
tout mais je suis je suis profond ment
ému et je suis heureuse et ça représente
quoi ce
prix ce prix représente une une
reconnaissance voilà reconnaissance pour
pour pour le travail que je fais de mon
côté tranquillement et et puis aussi une
reconnaissance de de de la professeur
que j'ai eu et ça veut dire qu'on y
croit pas qu'on est seul dans son
atelier dans son petit coin bah on a pas
besoin d'y croire on travaille on
travaille et voilà j'étais pas du tout
partie ni pour faire un prix un
concours vous ave dit quelque chose de
fort ça fait du bien l'art continue à
vous faire du bien oui oui oui l'art me
fait du bien et j'en ai besoin donc je
continuerai tant que tant que mes mains
marcheront je continuerai félicitations
encore merci allô fa un petit c un petit
tour sa case à saint-giletbain c'est
parti bonjour Alexandre bon ben on va
faire un petit tour et je vais vous
présenter ça c'est L simen déjà dès
qu'on arrive là alors ce buste oui c'est
je l'ai présenté l'année dernière au
prix séimen mais étant donné que la
priorité é donner aux femmes parce que
c'était le 8 mars mon guerrier n'a pas
eu de succès toujours aimé travailler
avec mes mains je faisais de la mosaïque
j'en ai fait pendant longtemps la
Réunion et puis après ben autre chose de
la couture enfin et cetera et puis je
vous dis la terre la terre c'était
vraiment quelque chose que que j'avais
vraiment envie de faire
et et les circonstances ont fait que
j'ai rencontré j'ai rencontré Sabine
Badinier qui a été ma professeure
pendant 3
[Musique]
ans une artiste oui si on peut
considérer qu'une artiste crée euh voilà
si on peut considérer qu'une artiste
travaille de ses mains ça oui je suis
une artiste dans ce sens- là tout tout
ce qui est produit avec les mains ne
sera jamais tout est pièces uniques et
ne sera jamais jamais identique même si
on veut faire une copie ça sera jamais
la même et et c'est ça qui me plaît
elle elle est bien elle est assise elle
est elle est bien bien assise sur le sol
je vais vous dire c'était ma première
œuvre donc pour moi elle est très
importante et je l'aime parce que parce
que parce que j ai travaillé et que et
que elle a elle a vraiment un comment
dire elle a vraiment une
attitude de
bien-être voilà j'ai envie de continuer
de continuer de continuer tant que mes
mains pourront me le permettre je le
continuerai en amatrice ou enfin j'ai
pas d'autres prétentions mais mais ça me
[Musique]
plaît
une belle soirée un beau moment pour ce
prellimen parce que rarement on donne
autant la place finalement au nouveau au
au nouveau de de la culture alors c'est
une belle soirée une soirée qui qui
tombe superbement bien puisque c'est la
journée de la femme et quoi de plus beau
de réunir des artistes mais le nouveau
c'est aussi qu'aujourd'hui on a réuni
des
artistes des collèges et aussi des
lycées c'est la nouveauté alors
finalement je vous propose d'inviter
tout le monde à venir voir cette
exposition jusqu'à la fin du mois ici à
la villa du département je vous invite à
venir voir cette exposition ceux qui
sont là aujourd'hui mais cette
exposition va rester là aussi tout le
mois de mars et alors on invite aussi le
tout public à venir et vous verrez ce
sont des artistes amateurs mais alors
avec un grand cœur avec un grand cœur et
vraiment on invite tous les réunionnés à
venir ici à la villa du département pour
découvrir tous ces œuvres d'amateurs de
femmes de jeunes enfants euh qui
représentent vraiment fabuleusement
l'art de la réunion de notre île merci
beaucoup bonne exposition et bon prix
séimen à vous merci
[Musique]
beau
cette année encore le succès populaire
de cette manifestation ne s'est pas
démenti beaucoup d'artistes beaucoup de
femmes sont sorties de l'ombre enfin un
cadre d'expression avec ce prix sellimen
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi merci à
toutes les directions du département qui
ont contribué au succès de cette
manifestation merci Michel à la
réalisation Manu à l'infographie et
Alexandre au cadre à bientôt sur 974
[Musique]
TV